welcome to this video playing the
Rainmaker from Estonia iím zap laughs
zap playing the French please playing
the advanced variation okay it doesn
ever mind submitted so much not not
saying that it is bad for white but
always felt like I'm I'm comfortable
here
yeah we can play many set up with them
kunai g6 night 95 like a plate many
possible on setups Oh interesting the
side don't really know what you can do
that maybe maybe in h5 here maybe g5
now that the Queen can be but i have
ninety-seven okay maybe h5 trying to
disturb his pawn structure if he goes
gphi they have 9725 you can do 90 725
now f4 night f5 should be quite nice I
think
yeah very very complicated position the
thing what is a bit um very Samus know
I'm a bit slow develop development wise
so some tactic might might strike night
be five or I don't know that could could
be a problem but at the moment I am just
threatening to take on III take on gt5
so this is something that he needs to
attend to with Queen d2 probably
amazing listen does not move is he
looking for something but I really take
III and take g5 I don't think you can
play right now and I'd be five or
something this is very substantial
threat only three
I wonder if he plays Queen d2 we are
what is happening if I play Queen to h3
intending night eh form is this a move
maybe wow he's taking it to extremes I
mean 22 is really a mandatory isn't it
why am I am I not really seeing things
right do I overlooked something I don't
I don't know Queen d2 takes on a 323
Bishop e7 he's got he's got a form so i
don't really see something can maybe
queen age 3 but still you need to play
Queen d2 here what else is there so
disconnected ice you sit down okay he
played this but I cannot believe it okay
come on can you take first thing later
check ok so I cannot take be five so
that much is clear I can take see one
however i can take see take mp3 of
course i would love to get my king out
of out of the age
hmm
okay well peep it wasn't totally crazy
to go for that what okay just just
should be seven maybe but this night c7
okay that I can take problem very tough
position check
yeah I really played all that because I
wanted to have a safe King now with
castling but can I really do that i can
check is 3m okay couldn't be seven
Queenie three years okay I guess his
king is also very weak text XD seven
takes it to we are thus this must be
right
yeah this might be possible t3
now the they're both hanging in a way
maybe try to play this Bishop to us
maybe okay I've h4 h4 takes on d 7 h
three yeah that's still a very fishy
line in a way take here for Bishop c5
are also not not going to work
yeah this is not what I wanted to do not
sure how bad it is but it wasn't exactly
what I planned okay mother bishop has no
great place to go time warning I can
maybe I can even take it yeah I mean
yeah why not actually if I get queen he
takes a five in this is a really big
Center and two pawns I had really
counted okay maybe get the bishop in
somewhere Bishop d3 e-form ok I'll see I
just see that he would probably don't
make the time white forfeits on time
yeah but it's a winner three pawns who
should be for coming yeah well this was
really really cool that you spent like
what two and a half minutes here to to
come up with with with this move it was
interesting but it was just terribly
impractical the thought of thing that I
could do yeah we thought that this is
normal but this this is a strong move
the computer indicates this so I was
right that this might be interesting
intending night to aged four and it's
tough tough to play for what computer
wants to do this and this is really ugly
even f6 as a move now
you are not very comfortable so this was
was cool I took computer once to play
rook c6 okay yeah well I took and took
this and now grabbed no play Bishop e7
yeah at least the computer is not giving
a win for wide or anything this is
reassuring just made the most practical
decision cm23 look the idea I need to
play all that there is not much much
else I think maybe around here him he
went wrong I mean maybe black is better
already that's possible but he I think
he he didn't really saw see that when i
get this he was thinking to get this n
bishop move and queen f6 play on the g
fat or maybe taking for a perpetual but
i just take the whole center and and
this is winning really yeah well i mean
if he wants to do this 9 p-5 he probably
should play it a bit quicker as this way
it was almost impossible to make the
time control alright thanks for watching